hey guys and welcome to episode 85 of
the let's play this episode is a tiny
bit hard to categorize all mostly it
there's loads of different things that I
was working on basically this was at the
end of my downtown downtime kind of
moments let's go over basically I was
just still kind of too uninspired on
when it comes to the Spanish area what I
wanted to do or what I wanted to build
and it just didn't work out
I just was like yeah all right I can't
let myself do stupid things over there
so just decide to just kind of let that
rest for a bit and force myself to work
on some other stuff where it's turned
out to be placing flags on the Main
Street because that was a very important
thing that still had to be done and
you'll see me spamming flags and
overusing them but in the end I think it
was best captures kind of run this main
area in the Main Street that means that
just with the flags like this it is
definitely not finished yet I like the
way that the buildings are there that is
all pretty much done but I still need to
get into the smaller details on the
buildings but also some crates on the
ground and interesting stuff it would
also be amazing to get some custom signs
or for example the gift shops or little
restaurants that I want to have on the
sides of those buildings but yeah I'll
get into that later since I really don't
feel like doing that stuff right now at
this it was just a tiny bit of pimping
the Main Street so to speak also with
these benches over here I was actually
looking at some Main Street some actual
real-life Main streets and well yeah I
kind of turned out that I had way less
benches and litter bins than some real
Main streets too so I figured yeah that
that would be alright fellow to fill
this area with I know that sounds
incredibly stupid and unplanned but I
actually did plan it somewhere kind of
it's just I I can't talk and that's why
it sounds like something stupid in any
case that is that's for this right now
it's just bench placing and that's
actually kind of also fun to just kind
of do it's kind of figure out and fiddle
with the smaller items rather than
having to go and do all kinds of big
planned things and stuff like that this
is just kind of I don't know there's
some times I feel like there's a
meditation or aspects to roller coaster
cone 3 and by the way I just moved the
menu down because I have the chats in
the top left corner that was an
extremely dumb decision but
moving on I feel like there is a
built-in meditational aspect in fact
like a second three there have been some
people who said that they like building
wooden supports I can't imagine even
liking lat
that liking that slightly but apparently
that there's just some stuff in roller
coaster can three that you can do and
just kind of feel like it's a just
something small something mindless that
you can do just to kind of not worry
about anything for a second but in the
meantime actually get something done
that somebody done that you think is
actually used for a good thing to spend
your time in which I'd like to believe
as well in any case this over here was
really just trying to attend a bit more
to this area than I had at the moment
and this was the only thing that I could
really do here and even as I'm saying
this and I think I've already two
episodes ahead in the future I still
have no idea what I'm going to do with
this area with the cue and how exactly I
want to do that and yeah I also kind of
want to hold back on that because I am
pretty sure that as soon as I start
building that cue it's gonna not be
really good so I still need to kind of
research the way that cues work more and
this stuff I might actually get some
people to give me advice on that but at
the moment I don't feel like it's safe
enough to be working on stuff like that
so that's basically why I'm just kind of
going around when and when it comes to
this area and just seeing if there's
anything that I can do add some slight
touches to buildings which you'll see me
doing like trims trying to add trims to
that warp and then looking at it and
figuring hmm that actually doesn't look
too good the back side of this building
obviously still needed to be finished
but yeah that's something that you know
I could talk about is the fact that some
people like to force themselves to do
certain things like oh this this kind of
place this little corner over here still
needs to be finished and I need to do
that before I move on because otherwise
I can't live or something like that if
you don't feel like doing it it is
probably the best idea to just do it
later on just ignore it for the time
being if it's not too much of a problem
which is kind of these small things that
I go to in this episode since I didn't
really didn't have too much inspiration
of what I should work
like I didn't have a clue I didn't have
the slightest idea what I had to do with
the area behind this station the queue
and all that but also I had no idea
whether I wanted to place a flat ride or
just a park on the other side of the
lake
so really doing the small stuff and not
really doing anything large that needs
to be planned beforehand was the only
thing that I could do though I did
mention at the beginning of this episode
I think that this was the last episode
of me kind of goofing around and trying
to fix some small things and this is
kind of true because halfway through
this episode I should actually be
starting to build some other stuff
around this area in any case this is all
just also kind of filler these same
banana planters are back except they
don't really look like bananas this time
I'm very sorry I tried my hardest but I
just needed something to cover up those
little gaps turned out that in the end
those little gaps that I wanted to cover
being those gaps where you still see the
water underneath the path coverage
because the path covers are like a half
tile wide but you can still see the
water underneath it from the
terraforming so I decided to place these
planters over them so you wouldn't see
them turns out that these planters
actually couldn't cover them either with
a mortise texture that they come with
so the gaps are still there just kind of
hidden underneath the shrubs and stuff
but from from like an aerial perspective
these plants is still kind of look
awkward but that's something to not
worry about and also probably something
I should have said I mean would have
anybody really noticed if I didn't say
that say it probably not but yeah that's
basically that then I decided to add
some some of these fun little things I'm
pretty sure they're not called a parasol
right I don't even I don't even know
what those things are called anymore I'm
language barriers hard in any case those
things and decided that I wanted to get
some tables in there like it's not it's
not really a full-blown restaurant yet
kind of just like the other restaurants
but I want to kind of spice that up
maybe with some smaller lights of course
a sign saying restaurant may be a fun
little bar I don't actually know if
those things exist like I've kind of
been looking for those but I can't find
them in any set and I don't know if they
exist but usually restaurants have these
like little menu things while they I'm
pretty sure they always do but they can
I don't know too much about that stuff
but they usually have these little menu
boards outside where they have like
their most tastiest and flashiest menus
and all that and I probably want to get
some of those I mean that's quite a big
step toward making something look like a
restaurant in any case this is I think
kind of the time where I actually got
some inspiration again as you just saw I
placed some white borders and they
suddenly just disappeared that's
something that I should talk about since
it might be a little busy right now but
basically I was live streaming at the
time I decided that I wanted to have
some paths over here some little random
Park work and see how that turns out and
if I turn out to be complete and utter
[ __ ] and decided to remove those white
things and everything that they came
with there were hedges and trees and all
that stuff and a day later because this
is actually the next day the kind of
thought about it and figured that I
needed to get a flat ride in here then I
could have the flat right action but
also kind of have a reason to get some
small parks in there and some trees and
planters and fun stuff so that's
basically why this ride is here I
figured it would kind of fit the theme
at least it doesn't break it and I could
add some small parks around that so
that's basically going to be the way
that this ride is going to look there
are like three openings it's and those
things that responses which you're going
to have trees and flowers in the future
one of the opening one of the openings
is just have random opening the other
two are the entrance and the exits and
yeah this kind of just gives a nice
little template to work with as soon as
you have these things up you can mess
with the benches the way that the queue
is going to be made the way that you're
going to do the foliage sure from this
point on there's not really much more
planning but just fun stuff with foliage
and I think in the end this is the
turnout pretty nice and it turned out
way better than the weird path covers
and things and I try to do first first I
kind of tried to make it into a random
Park but there really wasn't any
attraction of any sort and it just kind
of seemed random and out of place in any
case I decided to work with the path
arts over here again I know I've really
been doing that stuff way too often
lately and this probably still looks
quite a lot like the compost that I have
the entrance little chair swing ride but
it's something different I swear it is
something slightly different it's
supposed to be like a fun star or
something just a random decoration on
the path because I was afraid that if I
just added simple paths underneath this
ride that wouldn't be much to look at
and most importantly it would kind of
look a bit weird if you try to look at
this entire little square that I have
here from an aerial perspective so it's
there to make it just look more
interesting there's no real meaning
behind it or real idea but just a little
star thing and it was actually
surprisingly fun to work on though as
soon as I got those loose diagonals in I
was kind of worried about that and
needed to start messing with that so
that's why right now from this point
onwards I'll be stalling a tiny bit
trying to get all those right pieces and
then that took a very long time like
like you like you'll see I'm trying to
get all those pieces and there's so many
different pieces to choose from and they
have offset placements and all that so
that was kind of kind of confusing for
me I'm not really have that good at this
this type of stuff and in the end it's
not really any complicated path artwork
of any sort this is standard kind of
star shape I don't know I actually find
these things quite fun to make so I'll
probably do them more often in the park
plus it really is a way to kind of break
away from the boring straight path work
when nothing really goes on otherwise
and yeah I just think it's it's fun to
build but also pretty handy and it
worked with the right because the ride
itself didn't really have too much on it
like sometimes you have little fences
and rounded or some small scenery items
but I think yeah I may have actually
been some smaller scenery items for the
exits and entrances stuff like that it
did come with a custom scenery said but
I've honestly not messed with that too
much at this point I try to go for a
great path cover but that in the end
didn't really work out too well just
turned out to be a tiny bit too lights
tiny bit too colorless especially if you
compare it to the the rest of this area
which is also something to keep in mind
if you're doing like any type of area
with a certain given theme I always do
is kind of
like to give myself a it kind of a color
palette it's not really a color palette
and you don't really choose the colors
from it but a kind of general direction
that all the colors need to be in and
for this Mediterranean area it's
obviously going to be very warm colors a
lot of reds and yellows and greens and
quite a lack of Blues at whisky pretty
much all the Blues out of this area and
that's kind of just how that works so I
wanted to have that same type of color
scheme on this thing just some very
rustic and warm colors also kind of to
even out the incredible amount of green
and brown that I was going to have in
those planters so I suppose that in the
end that kind of works out I do kind of
like I do kind of like the look of it it
does have a bit of a tropical look to me
though but then again that's also fun
when I find a lot of fun about the
Mediterranean theme and actually why
it's been one of my favorites I know
that's a weird thing to say since
Mediterranean isn't really a theme I
would boil it down to either a Roman
theme an Italian theme or a Spanish
theme is that the foliage in those
countries can be very lush or at least
the way that you can represent them in
your well-wrought the cosec in three
parks of course and as everyone knows I
like to spend my ship and my tsipras's
and to pine trees and all that stuff and
you can get all those things in an Amana
Turanian theme but also a palm tree here
and there though as always limit your
amount of palm trees especially in a
Mediterranean area just have a couple of
palm trees here and there but really
keep it down to not that many because
otherwise it's really going to looks
proper call and palm tree jungles are
never a thing that's also something to
keep in mind especially not in theme
parks so like always be very careful
with using palm trees but especially in
Mediterranean areas you can use really
just a couple of them but don't go wild
with them because here's some simple
plan to work there really isn't too much
to this the issue was that I did have
those well hedges things around them
which could have been a problem in a way
since as nice as I think they look if
you look from the side
they are quite high and you just see one
color and one type of bush and that's a
a bit boring so I was kind of just
looking over here for flowers more
colorful stuff that is slightly higher
in larger than those hedges so you can
actually see that as well and that's
basically how these planters work but
not really that great and I could
honestly still use some feedback on that
if anybody has any ideas and anything by
the way just at any point about how
something should be done you can always
just leave something just leave a
comment about that but over here it's
just kind of insecure about these
planters and what I filled them up with
though I must say looking from a
distance or just looking at it from the
side it does look alright but I just
feel like in realism aspect I'm not sure
in well completely if it really works
out to have hedges like that and then
flowers after it just for the heck of it
but oh well it looked good and I suppose
that's the most important thing right in
any case at this point I started
building IPA and this is I think yeah
from this moment onward it is another
stream I think this was actually
recorded over three streams probably I
think so actually yeah and that's also
kind of why this video is so long I felt
like it was it was slightly too long for
a normal episode but it was definitely
too short to split it up into two
episodes so I'm sorry here's a very long
episode right now and in any case this
little Bulevar over here has already
made its fame as my incredible time
waster since despite how much time
actually wasted on trying to mess around
with this area where I now place those
teacups that used to be a park which
really didn't work I think I actually
spent way over an hour over here just to
get the lights right and what's even
worse about that is I was messing around
for about an hour to get the lights
right on this Boulevard and in the end
it just didn't work and I had to go back
to one of my old videos to see how the
past me did his lights and I just
completely forgot I just completely rip
ripped off my past maze lights and
whether that is stealing or just reusing
my own ideas I have no idea it could
honestly be a
kind of stealing like I am NOT me at the
time and I pretty well don't remember
coming up with those lights but that's
something also for the future is just a
tiny bit of ending decorations to the
path work which by the way it is a very
important thing when it comes to path
work the foliage and the details that
you add on it are half of the way that
the path work looks if you if you don't
place lights that really fit it if you
don't have enough benches and little
bins and especially if you don't get
enough planters or pots in which you
have flowers things like that your path
covers are going to look way less good
and its really hard to actually make
them work very well and it also kind of
works if you have a terrible path you
can spam many benches and lights and
well flowers on it and it will
eventually look decent I mean any case
these are the lights that I've been
talking about as you can see I'm try and
kind of try to start out with pillars
from the Main Street set kind of see if
I could support them in any way the only
thing was in my head the lights looked a
lot bigger than they actually are so at
this point the pillars are just way too
large break a barrier to the lights and
the lights are very close to the pillars
and I try to mess around with that quite
a while and it really just didn't work
out
yeah there are a couple of sets there
actually so much modern building at Metz
modern lighting set I think it's called
or is it just mass Lighting's I probably
mess lighting set I'm mixing up two sets
at this point banan case that didn't
work out after Ling lights didn't work
out whatsoever and for some reason those
things didn't even have a corner
placement so that was kind of confusing
so still need to look for other things
and at that point I think this is the
point actually where I found that
although footage though I'm not really
sure yeah
because there was also the problem I
looked back at the way that I used the
lights in one Park in Buzzard very long
time ago and I used pillars that I
didn't even recognize at first and
actually took quite a while and nobody
industry knew what the pillars were from
and then at some random moments my brain
just came up with it and then I was very
lucky to have heard that because
otherwise I probably would have been
searching for them for quite a long time
and any case here's also some issues
like voting ends lighting set for some
reason has some kind of connection to
the ground like it's not conforming but
if you move the ground slightly up and
down the lights above it are also going
to move slightly up and down which is
funny if you kind of play this place a
light and you decide to move the ground
underneath it but it's completely not
funny if you have lights on the
boulevard just kind of next to the water
like that where the terrain isn't
completely flats so that was kind of
painful for a tiny second there but
anyway if anybody wants to know about
these lights they're really not that
special it doesn't even require that
many sets it's just the tiny little
combination of some things it's mainly
Main Street one has a tiny little base
on top of that the pillar was from CTR
since she said now I don't know which
said there are two touch sets but they
both come in one set that sounds very
confusing
basically you download it as one set and
it comes out with like the Dutch
colonial set and the regular Dutch said
something like that and that's where the
pillar is from simple lights from
Bodines light kits with on top of it's a
little peak from Main Street one set and
some nice little hanging flowers from
station gyms gardening so yeah it's not
even that much work but I really like
these lights combining lights is
actually something that I always like to
kind of mess around with but in any case
that's it for this episode so thank you
all for watching and sticking through
with me in this incredibly long episode
and I'll see you all I will see you guys
next time